so I had to kind of come to the
realization that like okay not everybody
who voted for this guy is a bad person
right right
um but then I'm like okay but if you're
out here with a [__] Maga flag on
your truck pretty brazy that's that's
just a crazy like that's some cult [__]
it'd be like if somebody like I judge
the same type of human being if there
was a giant Joe Biden flag on your truck
I'd be like yo are we going to be that
fanatical about any particular
politician not everybody who drinks the
Kool-Aid is the devil but I've had to
come to a place where
I can recognize that just because
someone is conservative or might be
racist or prejudiced that it doesn't
serve me
to judge them and be upset with them for
like I was in this uh Russian like Spa
the other day in Chicago got this it's
amazing it's got the hottest sauna the
coldest cold plunge and yo it's hard to
find a spa in LA with the cold plunge
and the [__] jacuzzi the cold plunge
is so crazy but uh you know the dude
he's got to race his vibe to him you
know I can pick up on it right and uh
then I went in most recently and I saw
he had the um
he had conservative news channel just
playing in the common area right and I'm
like okay I properly interpreted right
you know this guy's energy but at the
same time it's like man that's between
him and God man I was leaving the mosque
one time and I've seen two brothers on
the corner talking there was a bunch of
Nigerian guys who were loudly debating
something as Nigerians do and one of
them was like man them Nigerian Brothers
they be deep man and the other one was
like man but they be racist and then the
first one was like that's between them
and Allah and I thought that was so deep
because there are a lot of
misunderstandings between us as black
people and Africans that I see both
sides of it because I'm gone in right
and I'm black American
um there's a lot of racism that goes
both ways uh I don't think a lot of
people are
hip to that that that's a thing that
exists yeah yeah that's that's that's
that's a reality but
that exists for us wherever we go
there's psychological propaganda that's
used to devalue Black Americans is used
to devalue Black Africans that's used to
pit them against each other because the
moment in time when we realize that we
have a unified front we have a common
enemy it would be too dangerous and too
powerful I mean that's why Martin Luther
King was killed that's why you know
Malcolm X once he started to move away
from a black separatism mind State and
embrace people of other cultures things
get really dangerous same thing for
Martin Luther King once he moved his
Focus From the March on Washington to uh
Poor People's movement
then he gets smoked because when you put
those dots together you connect those
dots then you get a red dot on your head
that's how it goes
but for me I had to realize like okay
this dude might be racist
yes he might be looking at me with a
certain Prejudice I can interpret it
that's between him and God like as long
as he doesn't try me what does it have
to reject that on to you you know he's
projecting it but as long as it's not
impeding my ability to do what I have to
do what does that have to do what does
it have to do with me so I feel the same
way about trumpism at this point it's a
lot of people that may be drinking that
Kool-Aid and caught up in either the
hateful ideology or rhetoric and racism
and anti-Semitism and a mixture of the
two but
that's between them and God I'm not
walking around mad like right I see you
you [__] with Trump and now I'm like
[__] you yeah I mean I'm not doing that
just
it's not worth it